Okay, so what is what does
this diagram look like to you?
We've got this box in
the middle labeled RL.
I won't tell you what that stands for.
And rewards and interaction with
the environment come in and
behavior comes out.
>> So it looks like that.
>> What?
>> Yeah, that's what it'll look like,
it looks like that it looks like that.
>> But
what process does that remind you of?
I'll give you a hint.
>> Reinforcement learning.
>> Yeah, okay.
So that's reinforcement.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, I want to contrast it with
inverse reinforcement.
>> I see, okay.
>> All right, so this if this
is reinforcement learning in
a nutshell, then-
>> It is?
>> Is it?
>> Yeah, environment and
rewards come in.
>> Yeah.
>> And then behavior comes out.
>> Right so
now I'm going to invert that, right?
So see how I change things?
I added the word, inverse.
I put an I in front of the RL and
I flip these two arrows.
So now in inverse
reinforcement learning,
the learner is experiencing
the environment and
externally from an external
source is experiencing behavior.
So this is coming from those same kinds
of demonstrations that you were talking
about and from that it has to
actually infer a reward function.
So let's do this as an exercise.
>> Okay, that would be kind of.
>> Not a quiz.
>> No, no that would be wrong.
>> That would be wrong.